entonces hay varios factores que son
responsables de esta este derrumbe
histórico de las fuerzas políticas
tradicionales que son el partido
socialista y la república factores
coyunturales y también factores que
tienen que ver ya con con elementos
digamos macro no hay que olvidar el
fenómeno marco el fenómeno marcó hace
cinco años hace explotar este sistema
bipartidista que ha gobernado francia
durante muchísimos años no hay que
olvidar las frustraciones que los
franceses sienten hoy en día no hay que
olvidar que en este momento lo que los
franceses están expresando mientras su
voto no es solamente la adición a un
cierto partido sino también el rechazo a
las élites tradicionales estos partidos
que sean digamos distribuido al poder
durante décadas
un sentimiento realmente de frustración
que va más que todo fortaleciendo el
foto tanto de extrema derecha como de
extrema izquierda entonces
además malas campañas digámoslo han
hidalgo valérie pécresse han tenido
dificultad para convencer a los
franceses porque les falta una narrativa
digamos más destructiva más sólida sobre
los cuales han podido vender digamos una
visión y un programa para el país
entonces ahí tenemos tantos elementos
coyunturales como más bien estructurales
que explican esta derrota tanto de la
izquierda como la derecha y este
fortalecimiento de los extremos